wir kommen noch zu einem weiteren
zuschauer fall wird verbunden mit klaus
densow er organisiert schlager reisen
wirklich mit 1400 gästen jedes jahr und
hat auch tatsächlich finanzielle
probleme hallo herr denn so hätten sie
haben sich bei uns gemeldet weil sie auf
geld von airlines warten wie kann ich
mir das genau vorstellen
ja es ist so dass die ernst bei dem
gebiet waren wir so können sich alle weg
das heißt also mittlerweile sind sie
nicht mehr zu erreichen die geschlechter
e mail nicht oder es kommen
seine begründung war umso besser und
weil deren länge anzügen es sind wir
reden hier von 1650 lösen will es dann
doch schon sehr dramatisch wenn man
dahinter seinem eigenen
es wird ja wahrscheinlich so sein dass
sie ihr geld wieder bekommen weil die
rechtslage ist ja relativ eindeutig
vielleicht wird es auch ein bisschen
ruckeln
wie sieht es im moment bei ihnen der
kasse aus fakt ist doch problematisch
ich habe gearbeitet meine gäste die sind
alle gott sei dank sehr sehr ruhig und
sehr entspannt und vertrauen hier auch
dass alles gut ist aber letztendlich ist
also ich habe jetzt seit mitte april bin
ich daran das ganze wieder zurück
abzuwickeln und laufe den selbst
hinterher
wir haben ein schreiben bekommen und mit
zahlungsziele nur um einzelnen die luft
jagen seitigen bekommt von ihren
einschreiten
dieses einsteigen wird geöffnet wie man
gucken ließ das nur durch praxis wieder
ein clip des schützenvereins schreiben
kommentare das ist ja da muss ich gleich
mal unseren rechtsanwalt befragen wir
haben sie so etwas schon mal gehört ein
einschreiben geht an eine
fluggesellschaft und die kleben stone
schickt es wieder zurück nein habe ich
ehrlich gesagt noch nicht gehört und ich
halte das auch für unseriös wenn das so
passiert ist wenn tatsächlich bewusst
der inhalt wahrgenommen wird dann ist
das absolut nicht in ordnung den
geschäftspartner gegenüber und ja das
ist auch wenn das so passiert
tatsächlich mehr als bedenklich denn es
geht ja oft um den zugang und deswegen
schreibt man ja post einschreiben
mit schreiben briefe damit man eben
sieht wenn der empfänger die post
bekommen hat und wenn der empfänger dann
naja den plan vereitelt zwar von der
inhalt kenntnis nimmt aber das einfach
wieder zurück schickt dann ist es für
den der verschickt hat doch gar nicht so
einfach nachzuweisen dass es auch
eingegangen ist also wie gesagt hier nur
mit dem einschreiben und rückschein dann
kann ich ja feststellen dass der brief
da war und wenn er dann gelesen wird
dann wird ja sozusagen der zugang auch
veraltet und dann entsteht so eine
zugangs fiktion aber das ist so schwer
bei gericht naja sagen wir mal sauber
nachzuweisen dass wirklich jemand dass
dort gelesen hat wirklich jemand wieder
beschreiben eingetütet hat halte das für
völlig unseriös deswegen immer auch per
e mail per fax
denn in vielen fällen brauchen wir gar
nicht unbedingt die unterschrift und nur
wenn ich die unterschrift brauche dann
muss ich ja normales schreiben stecken
also per einwurf einschreiben
beispielsweise wenn das so normalerweise
fristsetzung sind so wie hier
rückforderungen dann reicht auch eine e
mail und wenn wir hier diese dieser
größenordnung sehen oder das sind ja das
waren ja 1650 flügel wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe
sagen wir mal 100 euro pro flug nehmen
dann sind das 150 bis 200 bis 300
tausend euro sogar und die kunden sind
der gesellschaft in den veranstalter auf
der pelle die wollen ihr geld zurück und
die veranstalter kriegen ihr geld nicht
von dem nachunternehmer nämlich von der
fluggesellschaft super ärgerliche
situation und natürlich sagen unbedingt
dran bleiben und das würde ich mir auf
keinen fall gefallen lassen
und ich habe hätten so will sich das
auch gar nicht gefallen lassen
wann glauben sie geht es weiter mit
ihren schlagern reisen diesem jahr noch
oder wirklich erst im nächsten jahr also
die ich dann richtig mache eine und die
nächst es gibt denn jetzt ist ja auch
der vierten bis zum 11 und ich gehe
davon aus dass bis dahin auch noch lösen
wir das geld nicht sagen dann ins dorf
haben und das ist das alles ja auch
nicht nochmal passiert es klar da
wünsche ich ihnen alles gute und
lufthansa hat ja gesagt in den nächsten
wochen gibt es das geld zurück ich hoffe
sie gehören auch zu den empfängern
ich hoffe dass wirklich alles alles gut
ausgeht vielen dank herr denn so